The average time a person spends and
displacement or refugee spends and
displacement to 17 years.
That's just the average time.
We have people that are born and bred
and grow up in refugee camps.
The Syrians that have been sitting in
Syria,
in Jordan,
Lebanon and,
and then moved on to Turkey,
um,
have not been able to access the bare
minimum of,
of subsistence for themselves.
We have talked to people that have moved
on because they haven't found education,
decent education for their children,
healthcare.
And I think this really speaks to the
beginnings of the refugee regime.
The refugee regime was crafted in 1951
it was crafted at a time and a place
where persecution was the reason for
movement.
Civil and political rights were
privileged over economic,
social and cultural rights.
The idea of somebody moving because they
saw no future for themselves,
they saw no future for their family with
was somehow put in a second tier.
But what we are seeing now is precisely
people saying that that's not the way
that we can live our lives.
We don't have the right to work in
Turkey in Jordan.
We have no education for our children
and no health care.
So in a sense,
this is what you're seeing.
You're seeing the combination of a
governance system that is in desperate
need of fixing.